In this class, we'll be leveraging D3 to create interactive data visualizations.
Since D3 stands on the shoulders of HTML, CSS, JavaScript, and SVG, we
will need to get comfortable with these technologies before we start using it.
Although it's not required to know these technologies for
this course, much of the live code and exercises will assume that you
have a basic proficiency with each of these technologies.
If you don't feel comfortable with these technologies, we've included many
exercises and tutorials in the resources portion of the course or
in the instructor notes for each video.
I recommend taking a break now and
going to the resources section of this course now in order to
understand the code that is going to follow or if you want after this lesson
to brush up on anything that I may have covered that is unfamiliar to you.